typically the impact that renewables
will have on the existing power grid and
how it'll evolve over the next 10 to 15
years and what you'll see actually
Anna's talk was a great precursor to
what I'll discuss because none of the
ideas that she presented will have
natural hooks in some of the problems
that I'll describe in terms of mechanism
design pricing in terms of posted
mechanisms posted price mechanisms but
what I'll focus on is how techniques
from optimization namely optimization
leveraging on samples or data derived
from some unknown distribution can be
used to optimize the kinds of you know
it's optimizing the kinds of
applications that arise and power
systems with high penetration renewables
okay so when we say uncertainty what do
we mean by that there's two forms of
uncertainty that we'll consider in this
lecture one is in the form of supply so
you know many states have very
aggressive renewable portfolio standards
to increase the amount of energy that's
supplied from wind and solar hydro is
also renewable so dams or Pumped water
storage but those are limited in terms
of the geographic constraints if you
want to build a hydro facility you need
a mountain and a river so there's not
many places you can do that
so the supply of power from wind and
solar resources on like hydro is highly
variable by that I mean that it's not
dispatchable directly so the amount of
energy you have available to you at any
given moment of time is a function of
the wind speed or the solar irradiance
it's intermittent so it fluctuates
wildly you can go from so wind farm can
go from operating at full capacity to
zero and half an hour or faster solar
can fluctuate at much faster timescales
and the underlying physical processes by
which these variations are determined
are very difficult to model which in
turn makes it difficult to forecast what
the power production will be from a wind
farm over say 24 hours and so I've tried
to convey to you
how this variability actually manifests
itself in reality so this is data taken
from the Pacific Northwest the first
figure here represents or shows the
total power production in the Pacific
Northwest from wind over a day for every
day in one month ok so you can see that
there's huge day-to-day variability in
terms of power production profiles from
wind this this trace again represents
power produced in the Pacific from Wind
in the Pacific Northwest over multiple
weeks and what you can see is that at
some point when just dropped and was
totally absent for about two weeks ok so
if you're reliant on you know renewables
to meet demand ok a large fraction of
demand how do you do this when you face
such variability in the supply ok you
have to back it up but this backup has
to be done in an intelligent way which
leverages on techniques from stochastic
optimization finally this figure just
represents the difficulty in forecasting
so this is a 24 hour had forecast of
wind or sorry the prediction error as a
function of the prediction horizon for
wind power production in some region so
you can see the the the confidence
intervals can be quite large relative to
the expected value so again a basic
question is how do you schedule
dispatchable generation like coal and
natural gas
given uncertainty and renewable
generation that has to be absorbed into
the system that's a basic optimization
question which is highly non-trivial
given the underlying constraints and
embedded in in the power system that you
have to satisfy and by the way if there
any questions please feel free to stop
me so another source of uncertainty or
emerging form of uncertainty will be in
demand okay so today demand is largely
an elastic customers see a flat rate
most customers see a flat like for
electricity and they consume not taking
into consideration what that price
actually
and so we can predict demand - with an
extremely high accuracy say one to two
percent mean squared error twenty four
to thirty eight hours in advance and so
that simplifies power system operations
dramatically in the sense that you can
schedule resources in the power system
to meet expected demand and any residual
imbalance that manifests itself and in
real time will be quite small relative
to the forecast but there's a move to
turn the demand side into a controllable
resource to compensate fluctuations in
renewable supply so instead of tailoring
supply to follow demand you might tailor
demand flexible demand to follow a
variable renewable supply so there are
many ways in which you might control
demand either through price time varying
price signals or more sophisticated
incentive mechanisms but the the point
is by injecting some form of excitation
and the demand side you might excite
nonlinear dynamics or dynamics which
were previously unseen and therefore
increase the uncertainty in the
resulting demand profile over time
thereby making control of the system
more challenging so in order to actually
control the demand side in a way that
mitigates uncertainty you need
techniques from online learning and
stochastic optimization which can
simultaneously optimize the system while
learning the underlying model of demand
so as to converge to an efficient
operating point quickly so there are
basic problems in online learning which
emerge here that I'll touched on which
involve nice trade-offs between
exploration and exploitation
okay so the basic agenda I'll quickly
finish my discussion regarding power
system operations today again the models
I'm going to present they're almost you
know cartoonish but they're just meant
to give you a basic idea as to how
operations actually what they actually
look like today then I'll talk about a
number of problems one is related to
optimizing power systems with
uncertainty in the underlying problems
input data namely in the form of
renewable supplied it's going to be
available to you
another problem I'll discuss is how you
might dynamically price for incentivize
demand response over time in the absence
of an accurate model or in the absence
of a priori knowledge of how demand will
respond to the price signal that you
send to it and then if I have time I'll
talk about an experiment we did with
real electricity customers in New York
cities in New York City which revealed
some very interesting insight as to how
consumers actually react to price
they're actually quite irrational the
exhibit behavioral biases which are
well-known in the behavioural economics
literature but the point is they're
interesting opportunities I think to
design mechanisms and incentives which
leverage on these biases perhaps exploit
them to operate the system efficiently
and then Adam will talk about this is
very brief summary of what he'll discuss
the role of algorithmic mechanism design
and related problems in electricity
markets ok so again I said the system is
very complex so I'm going to present a
very simple description so this is the
control room and the Northeast so this
is there's a so the the grid is divided
into multiple regions with system
operators being responsible for
balancing the power system in their
local region so PGM is one such system
operator and they're responsible for
balancing this blue area here which
stands Pennsylvania New Jersey Maryland
they coordinate transactions market
transactions between hundreds even
thousands of agents on daily 2-minute
time scales they solve np-hard
optimization problems every hour
I'll describe that in more detail
briefly so the system is quite quite
sophisticated but the basic objective is
to schedule supply to balance demand on
a second-by-second basis this should be
done in a least cost fashion while
ensuring some level of reliability and
operating system or robustness to
failures or contingencies the market
design objective objectives are twofold
first is short-run efficiency you design
you should design the market in such a
way that the market participants are
incentivized to reveal private
information that leads to efficient
operation of the system in the short run
okay this is cost information primarily
there's also a long-run efficiency
objective which is related to the
creation of market signals in the short
run which incentivize expansion of
transmission and generation facilities
okay in the long run which are comprised
of the right mix so you want to build
you want to create market signals which
incentivize the building of a
transmission line in the right place
namely the place which will maximize
social welfare similarly with generation
so these are markets we won't touch on
but this just gives you a sense as to
the huge variety of an interplay between
markets and operations in power
okay so operations how do power up so
what do we mean by power system
operations the stylized model is
two-stage so Dane advanced the system
operator has a forecast of demand this
dashed line it dispatches generation
okay and again in a least cost fashion
to meet the expected demand this
forecast
okay this is done myopically in the
sense that it doesn't take into account
the fact that it will have a recourse
opportunity right to adjust or
compensate imbalances based on more
accurate information in real time so the
real-time adjustment obviously will
compensate any imbalances which realizes
which are realized based on the day head
schedule which was okay so this is a
two-stage stochastic program or
optimization problem which is solved in
a decoupled fashion
if you notice here again demand can be
forecast so this is actually real data
demand can be forecasted to within very
high accuracy so the resulting imbalance
in today's system in the real time is in
general quite small so the cost of the
inefficient use of information in the
setting is small and there are simple
stylized news vendor problems which
reveal this this trade-off in a much
cleaner way so at each stage is this the
operator solves like I said an
optimization problem known as optimal
power flow so day ahead
it'll schedule generation to minimize
the cost of supply to satisfy a bunch of
constraints so supply equals demand
according to Kirchhoff's laws the flow
of power across the network should
satisfy transmission capacity
constraints generation set points should
meet generator constraints and you might
have voltage magnitude constraints so
the voltages at different nodes or buses
in the transmission network should
satisfy certain bounds okay so this is
in general non convex problem both
because of Kirchhoff's laws you can
these are essentially indefinite
quadratic equations in the complex
domain and the cost of supply generators
have startup costs okay
so you know starting up a generator will
incur some fixed unit of cost regardless
of what its operating point is and so
that manifests itself as binary decision
variables in the problem in the absence
of these startup costs the OPF problem
is essentially a quadratically
constrained quadratic program which is
non convex the quadratic constraints are
indefinite so those of you familiar with
these types of problems know that the
most common relaxation is the semi
definite relaxation and there are some
recent results which have shown that for
certain network topologies these
relaxation czar actually exact and
Stephen Lo has very nice survey paper
formulating this problem and presenting
in detail the exactness conditions for
these convex semi definite
so markets again the cup the system
operator is minimizing the cost of
supply but this is private information
which agents have to reveal gain this is
procured through a market and so there
are interesting questions related to
efficiency of these markets at Nash
equilibria if they exist which they may
not in some cases so many and and I
guess the important thing to point out
is agents are bidding supply functions
which reveal their willingness to
produce power as a function of price
price and demand reveals its demand
curve which reveals its willingness to
pay as a function of its consumption
level so these are in general infinite
dimensional bids okay so many people
have studied the efficiency of these
types of markets I won't delve into the
details here Adam will touch on this
later but the point is there's very
little which is known about the
existence or lack thereof Nash
equilibria and supply functions over
networks power networks even linear
approximations of the power network it's
a very interesting problem okay so I'll
skip over this quickly because I touched
on many of these issues earlier the
increase in renewable supply and the
power system is going to amplify okay
the amount of uncertainty so whereas the
realized demand profile previously was
very close to the forecast in this
setting when you have a lot of wind on
the system and it's treated as negative
load namely ever all its pushed it's the
system operator has to take it you'll
realize a trajectory which is more
variable has ramps and can be quite
different than the day had forecast and
the the pink intervals they're
representing 90 percent or I think in
this case 70 percent confidence
intervals even forecasting Dayna
advances quite quite challenging and the
myopic approach that i described to you
earlier will turn out to be quite
inefficient in this setting
you're falling short of the demand how
long does it take before you can you
know does it get you there a lead time
in generating more power yeah so you can
think of this as so there are different
ways of compensating and balances at
different time skills so in terms of
markets or the use of market mechanisms
to compensate imbalances the fastest
time scale market depending on the
region is roughly 5 to 15 minutes in
advance of delivery so you can clear a
market 5 minutes before you actually
have to deliver power then in real time
there are automatic control mechanisms
which will compensate any residual
imbalance on the second or subsequent
time scale okay so the lead time is
about 5 minutes for the real time market
5 to 15 minutes so the point is we need
new optimization algorithms and Adam
will touch on results in the single node
case in the absence of a network related
to which have a firm grounding and
inventory control theory or multi period
news vendor problems ok
again the so this this gives rise to the
need to perhaps leverage on demand side
flexibility to compensate this
variability and supply with large
amounts from the ones so I'll touch on
both of these problems moving forward
okay so now optimizing power system is
with renewables the stylized problem
will we'll discuss is as follows I'm not
gonna kind of open the hood here and
unpack all these equations but this is
the basic problem that we'd like to
solve you'd like to minimize the cost
you would incur ok with probability no
greater than alpha ok subject to your
constraints being satisfied with
probability at least 1 minus Epsilon ok
so this is essentially an epigraph form
a chance constrained optimization
problem which again is np-hard in
general even under some simplifying
assumptions that I'll make I'm going to
assume that the power flow equations are
described by linear equations this is
known as the DC power flow approximation
and any recourse decision will have a
finite dimensional parameterization
in the uncertain variables with which to
which it's a function of so this
eliminates the complexity associated
with the infinite demand and
dimensionality of the recourse decision
space
okay so we'll end up with a finite
dimensional chance constrained
optimization problem and now we'll talk
about how some how techniques from
stochastic optimization might be used to
address or solve these types of problems
yes so I'll come back to that you know
so here yeah that's a good question
your objective like I mentioned earlier
was to determine generation set points
over multiple periods its ensure that
the system is balanced with high
probability no there's a system operator
who controls many generators so think of
a social planner well as access to you
know hundreds of generators connected to
different parts of the network the
system operator and there's also wind
with's injecting random power ok or
variable power of multiple time periods
this is an operator I'd like to
determine how to schedule these
generating resources in such a way that
this cost is minimized this is a form of
value at risk while ensuring that
constraints are met with high
probability this is in contrast to a
robust formulation in which you might
require that constraints are met with
probability one no strategic behavior
this is purely an optimization problem
so I'm assuming the cost so I mean this
is a problem that actually would be
solved right these are costs which are
revealed to you but then you have to
optimize given those revealed costs is
that clear any other questions ok
speed up a little bit so more abstractly
this is the kind of this is the problem
we're interested in you'd like to so X
is your decision variable it's in
dimensional and again you can interpret
X as being generator power outputs again
over multiple time periods Delta is your
uncertain variable so it could be wind
or solar power or even network topology
it could be used to represent
variability in the network topology you
may or may not have a line available to
you in real time epsilon is this
acceptable probability of constraint
violations so you'd like your
constraints to hold with probability at
least one minus epsilon and so again
because I put the problem in epigraph
form it's without loss of generality to
assume a linear objective in the city so
these problems are essentially
equivalent under the assumptions that I
I made below so the solution of this
problem requires both an assumption and
knowledge of an underlying distribution
some additional assumptions we'll make
is the set X it's deterministic to known
closed in convex and the function f is
assumed to be convex in your decision
variable X for each Delta for each
realization of the uncertain variable
Delta it is not necessarily jointly
convex in X in Delta or convex in Delta
okay we only require convexity in X so
if you knew Delta this would be a convex
optimization but we don't and so this
problem in general is non convex and
np-hard actually even for very simple
forms of F if X is by affine in X and
Delta and Delta is non Gaussian then
this problem turns out to be np-hard
even if Delta's uniform there are ways
of approximating these problems from
within using C so-called sieve are
constrains which arise from Bernstein
inequality approximations of these
probabilities but I won't get into that
but there's a very nice paper by
nemirovsky and Shapiro so I think the
biggest problem is this assumption at
least in the context of power systems
that you know the underlying
distribution P
in practice you don't and even if you
did the problem will be difficult to
solve and so the question that that we'd
like to answer and I think this is a
broader question the community is how
might one leverage on data taken from
wind farms or solar reforms to
approximate solutions to this art
problem in a computationally efficient
manner and so let's imagine we had were
able to extract iid samples from this
distribution P which may or may not be
known how might you use these samples to
efficiently calculate feasible solutions
for this problem I won't touch on the
issue of optimality but we'll focus on
feasibility here so the most natural
approach would be to approximate this
constraint using the sample average
approximation of the underlying
distribution this clearly gives rise to
a mixed integer program think of yes so
it's not difficult to see that enforced
because of the indicator function here
enforcing this constraint is essentially
equivalent to a combinatorial
optimization which is you know again
difficult to solve and of itself the
advantage of using these representations
the S n gets large the empirical
distribution will converge the true
distribution and you'll recover the
you'll get closer and closer to the true
optimal solution for the underlying
problem but what we'd like to do is
identify a way to solve this problem
efficiently using convex approximations
so one way of doing that is to
set the risk constraint or the
acceptable probability of constraint
violation equal to zero this constraint
then turns out to be equivalent to a set
of random convex constraints or more
simply a random sampling of your
underlying constraint functions so this
is a a tractable convex program it is
random because your feasible set is
random it's determined by the samples
that you've procured and as the number
of samples gets very large it's I think
straightforward to see that the solution
you calculate will converge the robust
optimal solution not the chance
constrained optimal solution so it will
be overly conservative if the number of
samples is quite large there's a very
natural sample complexity question how
many samples do I need in order to
ensure that the solution I calculate is
feasible with respect to my original
chance constraint feasible set with high
probability here xn hat will do no we'll
use to denote its optimal solution so
here calligraphic x sub epsilon is art
yes oh so yes so by robust I mean if the
random variable had bound its support by
robust solution I mean that solution
which is feasible for all realizations
of Delta over some support of the random
variable okay those problems can you
know it may or may not be tractable
depending on how you characterize the
support of the random variable the
deltas you have a support of Delta the
random variable right so this ellipse
here for instance
okay so there's a very elegant result by
camping and Calif you're a from a number
of years ago now which says that you're
a number of samples which is greater
than or equal to this number here then
you're guaranteed that the random
optimal solution you calculate will be
in your feasible set with probability at
least 1 minus beta so here the sample
complexity depends on beta through log
beta inverse and epsilon through its
inverse now the interesting thing is
this result is distribution free in the
sense that it makes it holds for any
distribution be under some regularity
conditions which are quite I think weak
it depends on it depends linearly on the
underlying dimension of your decision
space here n as opposed to the VC
dimension of the the family to which F
belongs to its independent of D the
dimension of your uncertain variable it
only relies on the assumption of
convexity of the constraint function f
in X so what we've done is we've taken a
problem which is quite difficult to
solve in general constructed a random
convex approximation which is guaranteed
dealed solutions which are feasible with
high probability they might be
conservative but if the number of
samples is not so large then you would
expect they be close to optimal but
that's actually an open question as to
how as to how one might bound the
optimality gap incurred by these random
optimal solutions
so for each scenario you will be having
a decision variable how do you implicate
obvious decision variable acts yeah it's
not for each scenario you calculate one
decision variable X but can be lowered
sometimes and you must be higher and you
must meet the demands with generations
so there has to be just one yeah so what
I did was earlier I made this assumption
here that my recourse decisions have a
finite dimensional representation so for
instance think that think of recourses
being a finally parameterize din
uncertain variables like wind
so when wind realizes itself I'm
requiring that the decision I take is a
fine function of that recourse and so I
just end up with the X here is just all
of these decision variables unraveled
into a single vector is that clear okay
so this is nice but there's there's a
caveat there's this assumption that the
samples you take are actually taken from
the true distribution in the context of
power systems there are two reasons why
that might be unreasonable one the
amount of data you actually have
available to you is not so much right so
if we're using samples from wind farms
many wind farms have only been around
for you know maybe five or ten let's say
ten years right if your samples are
daily wind power profiles well then you
only have roughly you know 3600 samples
right these predictions require that you
have samples which are on the order of
one over epsilon if epsilon is quite
small then you may require millions of
samples which you may not have available
so you might have to rely on a model or
an approximation based perhaps on an
empirical distribution formed by the
limited number of samples that you do
have available to you okay so the basic
question then is can one leverage can
one use similar techniques to
efficiently calculate solutions which
are feasible for this original chance
constrained problem using samples which
come from
the wrong distribution okay or a model
so you might think of your P hat as
being a computer model you have for wind
farms from which you can efficiently
generate iid samples and again these are
available to practitioners and this can
be done the basic the naive thing would
be to just take these misspecified
samples and use the random convex set
generated by those if the distributions
on close are closed you would expect
that these samples would be closed so
the histogram associate these samples
would be close to the histogram
generated by samples taken from the true
distribution to what you don't have
access and so one would expect that
given some notion of closeness between
distributions you might be able to
generalize these previous results to the
setting in which I've described here so
we need some notion of closeness or
ambiguity and distributions and so we'll
do is we'll assume that the model and
the the Soraa model are incorrect
distribution and the true distribution
live in some ball of radius R centered
at your model distribution okay so again
if P was formed as the empirical
distribution given some finite number of
samples from the true distribution you
could construct these balls using foster
Steen metrics or Komarov metrics such
that P would live in this set with high
probability depending on the underlying
number of samples you do have available
to you
but for now we'll assume that the true
distribution lives in the set with
probability 1 so here row we measure the
radii of these sets using some distance
from metric or distance over probability
measures so examples are total variation
Hellinger relative entropy I squared
and the important thing here is as the
radius goes to zero we recover the
previous formulation and so one property
we might like to a feature that we might
like our results to satisfy is that the
sample complexity results should recover
a campaign California's ult's as the
radius of this ambiguity set goes to
and and it we have a result of that type
so this is the sample complexity result
that we end up with using samples from
the Miss specified distribution depends
not on one over epsilon but 1 over nu
where nu as a function of both epsilon
and the radius of your ambiguity set so
if the number of samples satisfies this
inequality then these random optimal
solutions you calculate using miss
specified samples will be feasible for
your original problem with high
probability and nu here is a decreasing
function of R clearly so as R goes to 0
nu for these various metrics goes to
Epsilon for the chi-squared metric as R
goes to infinity namely as the radius of
your hand acuity set gets very large the
effective risk or probability of
constraint violation goes to zero in the
number of samples you derive blows up an
important thing to point out is that
under total variation for instance for
instance the radius of the ambiguity set
cannot exceed epsilon so epsilon here or
the acceptable risk of constraint
violation that you can enforce cannot be
smaller than the radius of your
ambiguity set as opposed to the chi
squared metric and that has to do with
the fact that chi squared is a far more
restrictive measure of distance than
total variation ur so this is I think a
very nice generalization of these
previous results and in the sense that
it answers I think of this important
question in power systems related to the
use of data that might be coming from
inaccurate distributions and how you
calculate dispatch decisions yes
forecasters uses last 10 days well may
be more accurate than joining samples do
you have something
so using using samples from a from a
distribution which is closer to the
distribution mean clearly a trade-off
would emerge right I mean there's a
trade-off between the number of samples
you require and the accuracy of the
forecast right so here really are is a
coarse measure of accuracy right here I
mean this is just the the perturb wrist
level here as a function of R and you
see the it tails off as differently for
different metrics as R goes to infinity
okay good so there's some open questions
here I mentioned earlier can one
construct probabilistic bounds on the
optimality gap associated with solutions
generated by these approximations would
be interesting there is some initial
work that's focused on generalizing
these types of results to non convex
constraint functions F so this would be
useful for the case of the AC power flow
problem or this quadratically constraint
quadratic represent a quadratic program
representation and finally they're
interesting questions related to
parallelization I mean the number of
samples you end up having to generate
and in turn the number of constraints
you have to enforce and solving these
problems can be quite large so is there
a way of decomposing the solution of
this problem into much smaller problems
where let's say you have a thousand
constraints instead of solving one
problem using 1,000 constraints you
solve ten problems each of which has ten
constraints you take only those active
those constraints which are active in
each of the sub problems and solve a
higher another problem which only uses
the active constraints from the smaller
problem so this is a form of important
sampling near the optimal solution can
one prove anything about
article methods to approximate solutions
these this is a hard question but it's
an interesting one okay so now let's
switch gears I'll talk about an online
learning problem related to dynamic
pricing a flexible demand and the basic
idea here is you have demand customers
who are willing to reduce their
consumption their willingness to reduce
as a function of price is private
information okay you don't know this so
as a utility or an aggregator you'd like
to set a price which maximizes the cost
savings you derive which are really the
benefit you derive - as a function of
the random reduction - what you have to
pay to them okay if you knew the demand
function then this would be a
straightforward optimization but in
practice you don't and so we consider a
posted price approach where the utility
will well I'll get to it okay so here's
a picture which makes this clear so you
have an aggregate or utility which
interfaces between demand side resources
say households and the wholesale market
the aggregator would like to buy demand
reductions from the residents using that
demand reduction I'd like to sell an
energy product into the wholesale market
so a reduction of say ten kilowatt hours
on the demand side can be viewed as a
supply of ten kilowatt hours in the
wholesale market that reduction is going
to be random okay so the amounts that
you offer into the market the wholesale
market is also random and if you turn
out to be short of what you had
originally offered you have to pay a
penalty and so there's an interesting
two-sided optimization problem which
arises here what price do you set for
customers on the one hand how much do
you offer in the wholesale market on the
other hand
okay and we're basically yes so that's
the basic idea so let's talk about the
wholesale market if you recall I had
mentioned earlier power systems are
generically operated dispatch decisions
are taken in two stages day ahead in
real time
well these dispatch operations are
coordinated with markets which clear
data in real time so nominally you'll
have a day ahead price which I'll call
PI and real-time and balanced prices and
I'll get to those in a second so if you
offer a quantity x day in advance you'll
receive a day ahead payment which is pi
times X you realize the supply s if
you're short you have to pay according
to the shortfall in Balham price Delta s
if you're long you get paid according to
the long imbalance price Delta L and
we'll make some simplifying assumptions
on the relationship between these prices
which we'll also assume to be fixed and
known that can be relaxed for the
purposes of simplicity in this talk
we'll keep those and there also other
details we're ignoring in terms of more
complex bids that this aggregator
utility can make in the wholesale market
so this is actually these markets are
run today aggregators can take small
residential resources be they
thermostatically controlled loads so air
conditioning units small energy storage
devices either in the form of electric
vehicles or wall-mounted batteries and
they can sell this capacity into all
sale markets there's known as the proxy
demand resource product - there are
several pilots which have been running
California the last couple of years so
this is real so how does the aggregator
listen the response from the demand side
resources so like I said we take a
posted price approach so the market
repeats over multiple days on each day T
it broadcasts a price PT each household
or customer will respond with some
reduction si of T for that reduction the
customer receives some payment PT which
is uniform price across customers times
si of t there's one caveat that I'd like
to mention
if s is taken to be a demand reduction
well clearly that reduction has to be
measured relative to some baseline which
you may or may not know I'm assuming you
know the baseline there's an interesting
question as to how you might actually
elicit or estimate baseline information
from customers and there's some there's
some nice work that's been done here at
Berkeley and camera show our pool is
group related to these questions so but
I'm gonna sweep that under the rug for
now I'll come back to that later so S of
T will call the aggregate demand
reduction at time T fine so we need some
model okay to begin to even reason about
how we might set prices so for the
purposes of this talk will assume that
the aggregate demand function okay is an
affine function of price subject to
additive and unobservable shocks okay
which are independent identically
distributed over time so we'll assume
that you have an affine parameterization
but we don't assume that the utility or
aggregate or knows these parameters nor
does it know the distribution of the
shock which because of the structure of
this problem the distribution will
actually turn out to be important so the
aggregator has to learn these things
over time so now let's kind of let's
take a look at the aggregators profit
and in total so again what of aggregate
is decisions at each time T on the one
hand asked off for a price to customers
on the other hand it needs to make a bid
into the hell sale market X of T and so
it derives the profit in the wholesale
market which is this term on the left
and a cost which is what it has to pay
for getting some demand reduction s of T
s of T is random so with aggregator
would like to do is to calculate the
price and contract energy bid which
would maximize its profit if it knew the
underlying distribution and demand
parameters then this is essentially a
straight forward news vendor problem and
you can characterize the optimal price
and energy bid which would be time
invariant clearly because I've assumed
that everything is constant
I won't get into the structure you're
Adam we'll spend some time talking about
this point is if you had full and full
or perfect information the problem is
trivial what if you don't know these
parameters so we take an online learning
approach okay so on each day T the
aggregator we assume has access to past
market history which is the sequence of
previous posted prices and previous
demand reductions we're assuming you can
measure demand reduction directly and so
it offers a quantity Eckstein to the
wholesale market posts a price PT and
observes the demand reduction st okay so
that manifests itself as some data point
here this repeats again over time as it
sets different prices it will see
different demand reductions and it can
potentially construct estimates of the
underlying demand model by which it
might through which it might myopically
optimize pricing water but there's an
important property that the price
process should satisfy in order to
prevent so called incomplete learning
and let's relate it to the rate at which
prices converge if prices converge too
quickly then you may converge to perhaps
an estimate of the model which is
inaccurate which would in turn lead to
you're setting prices in efficient
levels and so there's there's a need to
ensure some dispersion or excitation in
the underlying price signal you send to
the market so that you can efficiently
learn the model asymptotically or learn
the model exactly asymptotically but
clearly there's a trade-off right
you should the dispersion should not be
so large as to lead to poor performance
in the long run
namely unbounded regret so how do you
set this dispersion parameter which I'll
specify now in such a way that you have
good good performance so again the
pricing policy here should be causal
namely should only be a function of your
past information we'd like the price
sequences you generate to be consistent
with respect to the the Oracle optimal
price similarly for the energy bid and a
basic metric whether this is the the
most natural one to use is is regret and
so we'd like our regret to vanish
the average regret to vanish
asymptotically are namely we'd like our
t period regret to be sub linear in T so
here we're measuring regret as the
expected profit you would drive from
here the Oracle optimal decisions over T
periods - what you derive using your
policy okay so standard definition so
the basic law the technique we'll use
for demand estimation is straightforward
it's a least squares estimation so you
have price demand reduction pairs over T
periods you fit a linear model to that
data variably it'll be inaccurate we
also need to construct an estimate of
the underlying demand distribution so
what we do is we take the residuals
associated with this linear fit we
calculate the empirical distribution
associated with those residuals and we
use that as our approximate quantile
file to construct our approximate
quantile function which if you recall
our energy bed depended on okay this is
the basic approach to model estimation
that we're going to use
so one natural thing to do would be to
interweave a myopic approach to pricing
with this model estimation scheme which
would be at at every day t take your
estimates of the underlying parameters
and set the price in order to maximize
your one-step profit assuming those
estimates are exact you can show so this
will here we'll just do a simple
simulation is that you may end up
converging to the wrong estimates may
end up with incomplete learning and so
here your estimates of the model
parameters for the demand function
converged in correct values so the
dashed lines are their true values the
red lines are sample paths of your
estimates over some finite horizon so
they converge fairly rapidly but they
can to the incorrect value you end up
with similar behavior for your quantile
price okay so the in order to prevent a
complete learning I hinted at a strategy
earlier you might take your my Opik
price and then traduce some dithering or
perturbation to the price to ensure that
you have enough dispersion or variation
and your input so as the guarantee
asymptotic efficiency in your demand
model estimates and so what we do is we
take we use a very simple policy there
are many policies the many other
policies that one might propose which we
dealed similar results but for
simplicity of this talk this is the one
all discuss at every odd time step you
use the myopic price an even time step
you take you're myopic price from the
previous time step and you had a
perturbation which is order 1 over root
14 and what will well you can actually
show is is the optimal size of
perturbation that you should add in
order to guarantee that you achieve the
optimal order of regret in terms of its
dependency on T this signal introduces
enough dispersion so that you can ensure
asymptotic consistency in your demand
model estimation but the dispersion is
not so much that it leads to unbounded
linear regret okay and the senior is
some parameter that you could optimize I
can get into that it's what you can
prove is under this policy this perturb
myopic policy which introduces this
excitation to the myopic price you can
achieve an order of regret which is
square root T and this is actually
optimal you can prove this there are
several nice papers by a soft CV Keskin
and bebés which look at similar problems
in which they establish lower bounds
that hold for this setting as well
what's interesting here is I've assumed
that the wholesale prices and the prices
and also market are fixed if you allow
those to vary this introduces some form
of costless exploration in your in the
myopic decisions and so if those
wholesale prices vary the variation from
period to period is strictly positive
okay so here epsilon isn't some positive
constant that you can actually guarantee
you can prove that the myopic policy
achieves an order of regret which is log
t the interesting I think the
interesting then point out however is
that the constant which shows up ends up
being inversely proportional to one over
epsilon squared okay and so the amount
although asymptotically you triva log t
regret the constant could be extremely
large if the exploration and the
underlying wholesale price or this cost
this exploration is small okay so using
going back to our perturb myopic policy
you can show that you know this
perturbation is enough to ensure a
consistency
okay this is interesting here so this is
actually the the price sequence we
generate so there's a huge amount of
variation okay this may not be palatable
to customers there are other ways of
implementing these perturbations you
could employ phased exploration and
exploitation schemes where you keep the
price fixed for a number of periods and
then allow shifts over a limited over
some intervals of time which increase
logarithmically
with time but they're not all actually
I'll get to a point that is related to
this at the end so there's some
interesting open questions one is you
know here the metric we've used is gives
you a good notion of asymptotic
performance but in practice these
programs are one over finite time so be
interesting to look at policies which
have you know provable finite time
behavior second we've also assumed that
demand is in some sense stationary in
practice you know the customer
population may evolve over time
customers may be coming in and out of
the program how do you capture that non
stationarity in the policy you use you
might also experience customer fatigue
effects if customers you know see a
sequence of very low prices they may
drop out of the program after so
building these non stationarity these
non stationarity since the model would
be interesting I think the point I
alluded to earlier is related to kind of
this this idea of needing a baseline so
in order to measure demand reductions
you need to you need a baseline by which
to measure that that's something you
don't know and so the various ways of
doing this one way would be to estimate
it using similar days in the past
another way would be would be to use a
mechanism in which the customer might be
allowed to reveal a baseline so how
would you design such a mechanism so
that it's incentive compatible to reveal
your true consumption what what your
consumption would have been an absence
of
an incentive to reduce so again there's
some nice work here at Berkeley that has
addressed some of these issues and
finally different incentive designs okay
so this is a very simple mechanism that
we've proposed but are there other
mechanisms say lotteries which might
yield superior performance in terms of
the amount of reduction you're able to
produce per unit cost to the utility and
so I have a few minutes I'll talk about
an experiment we did which looks at
these different incentive designs and
you know we learned some interesting
things
it was very qualitative but I think
reveals some insight which could be
useful in terms of formulating problems
in this area are there any questions so
far
I don't have it in this okay let me okay
there is
there it is okay
okay so this was in collaboration with
Consolidated Edison in New York City so
here our objective with the control
air-conditioning units there are you
know roughly 6 million wall-mounted
units in New York City each of which has
a capacity ranging from 500 to 200 watts
so in total the mapping out of the peak
capacity if they're all on at the same
time would be 12 gigawatts that's
equivalent to several nuclear power
plants so the basic question that we
that I mean they've been doing this for
quite a while using the more traditional
incentive mechanisms that I just
described to you but the basic idea is
can you design incentives which would
induce customers to reduce their
temperature setpoint on very hot days
because on those days the utility faces
a very high price for electricity
wholesale market nominally the price of
electricity in the Oh mark is anywhere
from thirty to fifty dollars per
megawatt hour on these peak days it can
range anywhere from a thousand dollars
per megawatt hour to five thousand
dollars per mile it's very very costly
utility would like to shave the peak on
these hot days
so the basic control architecture is
that the utility has direct control of
the AC units there
so essentially switches that can turn
these things on and off and that control
is done through the internet and so by
controlling by being able to control the
switching of an AC unit you can
essentially affect this duty cycle there
by changing the temperature set point at
which it operates so you can actually do
temperature control with simple switches
the the customer agrees to participate a
priori and the way the events work is
Dane advanced the utility has some
forecasts of peak it alerts the customer
there's going to be an event tomorrow
okay and the customer knows what time
the event starts at 7:00 p.m.
anytime before that they can opt out
okay at 7:00 p.m. the customer will
increase their temperature setpoint by
five degrees okay and the vent runs for
four hours at any time in the program
the customer can opt out they could just
say look I don't want to deal with this
and they drop out of the program so
really here you can measure customer
performance or demand reduction as a
function of in terms of amount of time
they stay opted in okay so four hours
would be the maximum amount zero would
be the minimum amount so if we were to
use the the posted price approach that I
described earlier you're essentially
paying the customer the marginal benefit
you derive from that individual by
having his or her demand reduction which
in practice is quite small could be 10
cents per kilowatt hour or less and so
what you find is in connivance and
experiences problem for several years
people are happy to sign up but as soon
as they start seeing payments like it's
not worth my time you know I'm you're
only paying me 20 cents to increase my
you know temperature by you know five
degrees for four hours it's not worth it
okay so the the idea the key point here
is individual action has low value to
them leads to low value to the customer
okay but collectively the action of many
individuals you know thousands or
hundreds of thousands is quite valuable
to the utility in aggregate right and so
the utility to actually save quite a bit
of money by having a hundred thousand
people reduce their temperatures so is
there any way of instead of paying each
individual for their contributed
marginal benefit can you somehow pool
the total benefit and design a mechanism
which gives some people more and maybe
some people nothing exactly and so the
basic question here how many of you
would prefer 10 cents for sure or you
know a hundred dollars with a one on one
thousand chance so honey people would
prefer choice one how do you prefer
choice two assuming your risk neutral
choice two is the rational decision but
most people would go with choice - okay
so there are many behavioral biases
which might explain this behavior but
there I found this old paper by Laplace
or I think he has the beautiful
explanation he says it's principally at
games of chance that a multitude of
illusions support hope and sustain it
against unfavorable chances so I'm not
gonna get into behavioral economics
we'll just assume that people might
prefer these types of things so uh this
was actually inspired by some work done
at Stanford by Balaji Prabhakar and
decongestant transportation systems so I
saw this as a graduate student
well this might you know and that was
many many years ago this might actually
be useful in power systems and so the
the lottery mechanism structured as
follows
so it's tiered okay if you participate
for zero hours you qualify for nothing
if you participate fret for in between
one and two hours you qualify it to play
for a Tier one reward which is five
dollars there's 50 of these okay so I'll
explain how the the rewards are drawn if
you participate for two to three hours
you qualify for a tier two or reward
there's $25.00 and if you stay for the
entire amount of time just four hours
you qualify to wait a hundred dollars
okay which is non-trivial the only two
of those rewards so the program we ran
actually only involved 200 customers and
so you could map these tickets to
probabilities the customers know which
they did one thing this is also caveat
when dealing with kind of residential
customers you also have to take into
account the fact that they have limited
ability to actually a time rather to
understand sophisticated mechanism so
that goes back to a point Nana was
making earlier simple mechanisms are
valuable in that they can be understood
more easily by customers so again the
the drawing is as follows if you've
qualify for Tier four if you win you
take the hundred dollars and leave the
lottery if you lose you waterfall down
to the next year and are included in
that drawing if you win you go out
otherwise you continue cascading down
until you either win or get nothing and
leave the my case so that we had two two
groups each of which consisted of two
hundred two hundred households the
lottery group and the fixed rebate group
which received roughly $2 per hour of
participation okay so that's non-trivial
it's much higher than what they're
actually the value they're yielding to
the system okay so we thought let's
let's let's look at the extremes of this
program and see if we can still show
that a mechanism like this improves upon
it's non-trivial fixed payment so there
were five events over the summer
and these are the results so the what
I've listed here are the statistics
associated with the participation time
in each group for each event there were
five events so consistently the lottery
group has an average participation time
which is higher than the fixed payment
group and also notice that the variance
in the response was less the interesting
point is I think one interesting point
is that the this difference was most
pronounced on the hot day okay which was
later in the program and so somehow the
lottery was more effective at sustaining
customer participation on hot days than
this fixed rebate incentive so the
average cost the utility at the end of
the day in terms of the margin average
marginal cost is roughly seventy cents
per hour of customer participation time
the lottery group and again two dollars
per hour participation time in the fixed
rebate yes yeah so again this is the
real world right I mean so we have we're
controlling these units through the
internet there were times at which
somehow units were not available either
a customer had unplugged or there was
some failure in their wireless
connection at home their internet
connection it's not no no no so these
are these are not due to opt-out numbers
these are due to just these are the
number of customers who are we could
verify we're available what do you mean
by the split so when there was 200 we
allowed 200 participants in each group
and one thing I should mention is the
customer self selected so when we open
the program out we allowed customers to
choose that here are these two
incentives you pick yeah yes this was
not meant to be a rigorous experimental
trial just meant to gain insight okay I
shouldn't even call this experimental
results
so these are just histograms of the
participation time and each group yes
no that's a very good question actually
I mean the reinforcement effects which
will kind of touch on briefly at the end
are not they haven't been well studied
and programs which run for longer
periods of time but there is one insight
that we qualitative insight that we
derived is there are ways of reinforcing
kind of a customer's affinity to
participate in these programs and that's
namely just giving them something small
more frequently and so if I boost the
probability of very small rewards that
can amplify these biases to participate
these type of programs so that's an
interesting question I don't know but
it's perhaps worth exploring and more
controlled experimental environment so
again these are the cystogram so the
blue is the lottery group the red is the
fixed payment group and it's a histogram
over participation times and you can
clearly see that the lottery group has a
fatter tail on the right people were
staying in for longer periods of time so
this was the hottest day again the
difference is most pronounced on the
hottest day some hottest day you can see
that many people in the fix payment
group opted out immediately while the
majority of people stayed and stayed in
for the entire amount of time in the
lottery group okay this is an
interesting figure this so this compares
the the dependency of customer
participation times as a function of the
average outside temperature over the
event time so you notice is so here the
solid lines are the means the dashed
lines are the medians and these boxes
are the inter decile ranges the
participation time in the fixed payment
group decreases with increase in
temperature but you also get an increase
in variance and response and this is
this goes back to this earlier comment
they made at the very beginning of the
talk that
trove incentives which aren't carefully
designed might actually amplify
uncertainty in the power system okay
whereas in the lottery group here you
can see the the variance in response is
somewhat insensitive to temperature
variation so is the average
participation time so interesting
interesting observation not enough data
to say as to whether this holds in
general but I won't i won't parse this
table because i've gone over time but
the point i'd like to make it there are
reinforcement effects and the sequence
of rewards matters so we we noticed that
customers who received something
initially and then lost on average did
you know provided more to the system
than customers who lost initially and
then received something later so there's
some initial conditioning effect so it's
important to give somebody something
initially so that you kind of have some
how that leads to the largest
application of this bias
so I'll stop there I guess the one point
I would make is customers you know they
may not be rational a normative sentence
and so hey you know using techniques
from you know online learning or
stochastic optimization which relies on
data to build models I think could be
quite valuable in this setting as it
might allow for a richer class of models
which could be optimized against so
that's it so instead of incentivizing
what if you penalize
what do you think that would actually
help yeah I mean you know so this is
kind of the stick versus carrot debate I
mean it's difficult it's difficult to
use a stick at present because of but if
a utility decided I can't I can't just
say I'm gonna force you to participate
in this experimental program so as to be
optional where they're paid for
providing something to the system as
opposed to being penalized for not
providing something but in the future we
will you know I think converge on
mechanisms of that type because there's
no need to measure baselines right you
just increase price when for the
customer when the wholesale price is
high and they'll reduce their demand
that's it but it's difficult to do at
present but that's you can give them a
cup fronts on the mouth and then if we
go to participate they cube it
so this yeah that's actually related to
another incentive design that a utility
in Singapore used was they they required
customers to pay for their electricity
at the beginning of the month okay and
so they'd have these credits and they
could see how the credits were being
depleted over the month and so they
found that they were actually able to
reduce demand by just having customers
pay closer attention to losing money so
yes
inspiring us there's something about
it's sort of like the visibility of the
people who win big making a big impact
yeah yeah so if I think you know if I
see my buddy or my neighbor want a
reward right it's like well actually
there's a chance of winning perhaps
right it might amplify my yeah so we
haven't studied that explicitly the
mechanism we're running now is I've
we're designing that we will implement
is a procurement point mechanism where
buildings have to collaborate so they
they only receive a payment if they meet
some threshold and demand reduction and
so you know so these ideas of leveraging
on social interactions and group action
I think is interesting but slightly
different